let's start good morning my name is
Gustavo Pitino at Oakland University
William Baumann School of Medicine I'm
actually a neuroscientist and teach
neuroscience there but today I will be
telling you a little bit about the
struggles I've had trying to make my run
code faster and this partially stemmed
that a lot of my research interests are
in running computational models of
neurons or heart cells and we try to do
a lot of differential equation numerical
approximation because these are
equations that don't have an analytical
solution so before we start can I have a
show of hands how many of you have tried
to do specifically parallel processing
if in your complete team did you get our
notebook okay so and how many of you
have tried to do siphon in general and
within the jupiter notebook alright so
we're gonna be focusing a lot on the
jupiter notebook and let me tell you my
disclaimers so because I come from the
biomedical sciences like I have to tell
you I don't have any financial interest
I also have to warn you I am NOT a
computer scientist so don't get too hung
up on the code if it's like really bad
code and there's a lot of annotations
because I have to really write down what
I'm doing at every single step but let's
try to just focus on the different
comparisons that we're gonna make today
and of course the biggest warning of all
which you already know is that if I say
optimization you can say is the root of
all evil so don't do it too fast now let
me tell you a little very quickly what
is the problem that we're gonna try to
solve today with the code and in doing
that we're gonna be able to compare
different ways to try to make it faster
again within the jupiter notebook and
let me tell you why i wanted to have
this session in the jupiter notebook in
in the biomedical sciences we use the
notebook as a way as our lab notebook to
keep track of all the things we've tried
what kind of things have war what kind
of things haven't worked so much but
what you find is that a lot of the
libraries that are out there their
performance within the Jupiter notebook
only allows a subset of those available
commands to actually take place so the
idea of the session today is to give you
a reference of from those libraries that
you have heard these are the things that
really work within the notebook and this
is how they are implemented but again
they will only be a subset of all the
commands that are usually available
within that library so if you run it on
Idol or any other IDE you'll have access
to much bigger things and especially if
you then actually compile that code
using using bash then you'll get even
more access to those things so as I told
you I do a lot of simulations of how a
neuron behaves how a heart cell behave
and the way we simulate those those
systems is using systems of differential
equations systems of differential
equations can become very computer
expensive so what we're going to try to
do is just approximate a very simple
function the y equals x square function
using its derivative which is going to
be y a y prime equals 2x and for that
we're going to use a very simple method
to numerically solve differential
equations called the Euler method in
which we have to start with a value that
we know for X square and then to
calculate the following value we take
sorry we take that same value and we add
a step size that we have determined
times the derivative of the function
that's all what we are going to try to
do this is a very simple method is not
very used in our actual scientific
environment because it's very imprecise
very quickly you accumulate huge errors
and I'll give you an example of that so
what we are also going to try to do is
when we run this function we want to
determine the
minimum step size for the result to be
within a specific tolerance that we are
specifying us one to the minus five and
we're just gonna run it for a million
points these will allow us to better
compare like how long different
functions take in running a million
different points at every single step
but because we are running a million
points with different step sizes the
final number that we are calculating is
gonna be changing why we are not gonna
care about that the question is like if
you have a later million points how long
does it take you to find the minimum
step size for the difference between the
approximation you lured a derivative and
the actual function at the last point
everybody clear on what we're going to
try to do any questions okay then let me
just switch to the eternal book we get
it
and so you'll see the one the notebook
that you had in in github they had not
had the cells run here I've run them
just because some of them will take a
few seconds and it might get very
awkward we have to all sit here in
silence waiting for it to run but
basically this is my definition of the
function we want to approximate we get a
million a million numbers and then we're
going to calculate their squares we are
also going to take the first one of them
and run the Euler approximation for a
million more points and at the end we're
going to calculate what the difference
between this point squared and the last
point of that approximation and we
return the absolute value of that
difference and just to give you an
example of how errors accumulate within
this function by the end of 1 million
evaluations with a step size of 1 they
there is an error of 5 to the 5 times 10
to the 11 which is 500 billion between
doing 1 million square and approximation
using the Euler so it's a huge
difference and that's that's why we have
to keep reducing the step size until we
actually get to a difference we can
tolerate so we're going to start running
in a while loop these approximations
with given step sizes and if our
difference is above that tolerance then
we are going to divide the step size by
10 and we're going to continue iterating
until we find the step size that gives
us a good tolerance and we are printing
at the end outside of the while loop
they their step size that we find
want you to notice a few things there's
two four loops in this function and we
are adding another level of hydration
here with this well so within this world
you're going to have two for loops
that's what's gonna make our
computations very intensive and it's
gonna create the deletes that we are
actually gonna be be studying and if you
run this one if you run it in your
computer you'll probably get different
numbers depending on what other things
I'm running in my computer I get
different numbers but in general we see
that without any optimization use using
basic Python code it takes ten seconds
to find what's the best step size that
we get and we see that the step size is
1 times 10 to the minus 9 so let's just
write it here that basic Python takes 10
seconds if we use seitan which is a way
to compile Python code to see everybody
knows what psyphon is all right so I
don't have to tell you how it works
I from what I understand it does what
tries to compile these within the
jupiter notebook and then run it and it
shows you the difference you're gonna
have a lot of functions with insight on
but in the jupiter notebook you're
basically limited to one thing which is
gonna be do static typing and the static
typing is gonna happen as the cdf in
case you're defining a variable and you
define the type you have float int you
have list you cannot use the cdf for
when you try to do a numeration x' or
iterations like this and for that before
in the jupiter notebook you have to load
the extension siphon and define your
function within a cell that has the
siphon magic
and if we run that again we're gonna do
the time it with the same code we had
before all we did was sight oh nice the
function the error Euler function this
brings down the execution time to 599
seconds per loop or 6 seconds per la
blood I'll just keep it at $5.99
one question that I've had before is
okay but maybe it was the first time
that he was compiling the function maybe
if he'd already compiled it it's gonna
be able to do it faster so if you decide
to run it again you're gonna see that
the execution that you get is pretty
much the same in this case was 598 and
that's because the compilation is
happening when you run this cell another
question is could we time while trying
to do this within a scythe on cell and
have you guys ever tried to combine two
magic commands in the same cell it
doesn't work you can only pick one so if
we wanted to get this timing we had to
we could not optimize this while loop
using siphon okay okay but if you look
at the code you're gonna say like you
have it your code is not really
optimized by itself which is what you
usually do like when you're writing a
program the first thing you want to do
is write it in a way that takes
advantage of the datatypes and the
library is that the program always has
right and because of the definitions of
those lists many of those lists which
could turn into an umpire race so it
should be Valley to say why don't you
use numpy within your within your code
so we can write a new version in which
we're using non pipe to create different
arrays numpy or arrays that are much
faster than lists and let's see how dad
is gonna execute and you can see that
here we change the range from before to
an umpire range and again if you run it
just with the same time it what you end
up getting is an 835 second performance
which is is an improvement compared to
the ten seconds the
get
now I'll tell you that many of these
performances are going to be very
dependent on the state of your machine
anything that you have running on the
background will definitely impact them
how they're happening nowadays with
containers when we can always a spin up
a new virtual machine with exactly the
same state over and over again I think
you'll be able to get some consistency
in the performance that you can get but
if you try to run it on your laptop is
gonna of RI a lot these particular one
I've had it changed between seven
seconds eight thirty five seconds it's
always worse than syphon but the this is
actually very close to the 10-second
mark that we had with a regular Python
one thing
did you guys hear yesterday are they one
of the keynote speakers when the person
from continuum analytics was saying how
a lot of things are already optimized on
the background when you run Python we
think anaconda so one of the things that
I wanted to check with them is like well
if all this optimization is happening in
the background when I try to do this
kind of things I'm not seeing a big
difference is it because it's already
optimized so is it worth it for me to
still try to keep optimizing my code and
what the Anaconda representative tom is
that you should still always try to
optimize your code because the level of
parallelization and optimization that
they are able to do without knowing your
the exact specifics from your code it's
always going to be very general very
initial so you can still try to get
these earnings now keep in mind that we
are trying to run something that just
fits in my laptop we're only
a million samples at a time before doing
the next iteration so as you start
growing in scale and especially
especially if you are trying to do data
analysis of a huge data set all these
things will start a lot of them start
approximating oh and performance
depending on the specific algorithm that
you're using so with enough sizes even
these small changes will accumulate and
give you a big difference in performance
another optimization that we have
available is the site by library which
has specific modules for integrating
differential equations anybody works
with differential equations here you
guys are very large I'm sorry to hear
that but in general consider yourselves
very lucky so let me give you a quick
showing of how this I pie solves
differential equations so we have a
specific class that when we defined one
function that just has our derivative we
provide some initial conditions you
instantiate the the ordinary
differential equation class with the
function that you have defined you set
the initial values and then it creates
two objects solver T and solver why T is
going to be the dependent variable Y is
going to be your independent variable Y
is going to be the Y in our original
equation of y equals x square and T is
going to be the one that corresponds to
DX and if you call them you're gonna see
that they start with initial conditions
that you provided if you input a new
value to that object Saint Sauveur
called a method integrate is going to
return if for an X of 20 I can integrate
it to a final value of 400 which
corresponds
20 to the square so notice how we just
can input our our values and is gonna do
a very close approximation even studying
with the same definition of the
differential equation that give us huge
problems when we were running the Sam
the plain Python and it's because again
these libraries highly optimized to
solve these problems so you can say like
well then we don't need to find a step
size we can just put I integrate 1
million and find if the answer is the
same one as we get doing 1 million to
the squared which is fine one thing to
keep in mind is that solver white does
not take NPI arrays as input so let's
just still test it by running it a
million times each time putting a new
number in to integrate and again I'm
showing you here how that's going to be
implemented and basically we're just
having our array of numbers from 1 from
0 to 1 million we find the square
numbers and then we're gonna run the
solver integrate in putting each one of
these numbers and we'll see what's the
absolute difference based on what I just
showed you what would you expect that
absolute difference to be we should be 0
right because it should be able to tell
like oh did you give me 1 1 million I'm
gonna calculate exactly 1 million square
and this time we're not gonna try to
find a specific step size and I'll tell
you why in a say or you'll see why we
are not doing that we're just gonna run
these solver integrate a million times
and see what we get so we do this time a
server print the this function that we
just defined calling the integrate a
million times and you find that we have
a difference is very small but because
of the
numerical representation of these huge
numbers that are not exactly in the
computer we star accumulating very big
differences at the end still a
difference of point zero zero four is
above our level of tolerance but is way
better than the five times ten to the
eleventh that we were getting originally
with the initial with the initial Python
code I notice had this one it's is not
very different from the ten seconds we
get with plain Python but with this you
didn't have to find what else what does
more step size would work best for you
in terms of getting a very good a very
good exact result you can always input a
smaller step size and see what happens
then you see that the performance
doesn't change that much but the
precision gets much better so that's the
advantage of those differential
equations over so in this is going to be
to in general of side by side by a lot
so whenever you use side by a lot just
keep in mind that in terms of the
performance time it won't change that
much so it will make you get the results
faster of just having to code ones and
not trying to optimize for those hyper
parameters like the step size in this
case is but it will also give you very
exact results and that's a big advantage
of site pipe so that one we had nine
point sixty nine
so seitan compiles Python code to see
and tries to run that C code now how has
anybody used number before how do you
like number it's great so do you
understand how what number those with
the Python code yeah so it's hard to
argue with that and you because I'm up
here I felt compelled to try to figure
out how number works so I'll tell you
guys what I understood but if anybody as
I said not a computer scientists if you
really understand it much better feel
free to raise your hand and give us a
better description and whereas syphon
compiles to c code number takes
advantage of the low-level virtual
machine and tries to use that more take
the Python code moves it to the
low-level virtual machine and from there
is able to optimize to get to machine
code it works specifically good
according to the documentation we numpy
and is specifically taking the raw
Python code detecting areas that might
work better as a non pipe object turning
into that numpy object and then
optimizing it at a low-level virtual
machine anybody has heard anything
different so then let's go let's just go
with that and as you mention nobody
super easy to use
so number is already when you install
anaconda and in case you have an upgrade
and I contain awhile there's been a lot
of packages that now come directly in
anaconda so definitely do an upgrade if
you spend more than a year since you do
but you can just call from number this
function JIT then you say this new
function is going to be the JIT version
of my initial function that's all you
need to do and that you just run this
new function and we get pretty much the
same results
notice how we've always been getting one
times ten to the minus seven one times
ten to the minus nine which I just think
it's a matter of the representation of
such small numbers but now look at the
performance time and you didn't have to
do anything
you wrote the code just the Wagin you
know how to do it and then run go send
it to JIT and that's it you run it and
now we have 471 milliseconds compared to
10 seconds that we started with so if
you haven't used number I highly
recommend that you do it there's another
way to do it and instead of doing this
you can just have your same code that
you had before and in the cell you put
the decorator at jeet and then now a
function that you write in that code
block will be defined as a number of
function but again when you go to time
it you can just call it the same name
you had there so it's very easy to use
what if we one caution that it will give
you is that remember in this plain
Python code we were starting with lists
and sometimes in my experience number
has given me issues accepting lists this
is not the time I can't I haven't been
able to figure out when is it gonna give
you an issue for having lists when is it
gonna accept them I don't know if you
had they the same yeah so just keep that
in mind if you try to run your code and
it gives you a problem my experience is
first let's try to find if there's a
list if there is if there's at least try
to get around it
and then it might work if you run it not
like this but with the decorator add G
the performance is the same so you don't
have any difference in terms of that
so let's try let's try now to use that
JIT compilation with some of the other
other models that we had that can get
faster so I try to do with the sytem one
it doesn't work you cannot combine
number with syphon let's try with the
non pipe and what we get is that now the
performance degrades a little bit it's
still super fast but it's definitely has
degraded to a hundred milliseconds more
and I haven't seen that the commutation
that's like exactly why this might
happen from the documentation one
possibility is that because nama tries
to take your raw code say which parts
can I already optimized as an umpire
object if you have those not by objects
there then you're not going to be able
to to take advantage of that step and
there might be some conflict in like oh
you already have some numpy there I
might have to run something else and see
if I can optimize it better or or no but
that's just my impression but again
notice how many of these things are not
accumulative the gains that you get with
one technique don't add to the ones that
you're getting from another technique
okay
how many of you have done parallel
processing in Python before okay what
kind of modules have you used for that
okay which other ones MPI for pi yeah
that's what you say right yeah
MPI for PI so dusk which there was an
awesome tutorial on Friday if you
weren't here for that definitely go
check the videos frozen oh that's true
thank you there's also on Friday there
was also the tutorial on concurring
futures I found that many of them
require you to kind of understand some
of the workings of the parallel
processing so I'm just gonna tell you
about the I PI parallel which i think is
like the Gateway for trying to start
working with these with this parallel
processing in Python and trying to make
sense of things one thing that I PI
parallel requires is that first you have
to start the IP cluster object in your
terminal and let me show you how that
looks so in your terminal you just enter
IP cluster start and at the end is going
to tell you how many engines it starts
it will start one for each of your
course so if you like me had no idea how
many cores your machine had these will
tell you exactly how many are there then
you can go back to the Jupiter notebook
import from the IP parallel library the
client object instantiate that object
and this instantiation
is going to be able to create a view so
this V is going to be that view of that
instance and we can say we can we want
to create a view of how many of those
course okay and if you just do like this
it will create a view for all the course
which we're going to do in this case
because we are going to want to send
portions of our task to each of the
course but you can say no just show it
to me for the first core or the second
core and to confirm another way to
confirm how many cores or engines you
have running in theory it should be one
engine for each code you can do our
cidade ideas and we return four numbers
for the four cores in my computer the
part that I personally always have
trouble with is I know I want to run
this in the different course but many
times that requires my code to be
changed
make it parallelizable so that only
certain portion will go to each of the
course and I don't end up running like
in the beginning I would always end up
running the same code four times in the
different course and getting the same
answer from all of them which kind of
defeats the purpose of the whole thing
so here what we're gonna do is again
we're gonna send our initial function to
the different course but when we send it
let me say it you when we send it we're
gonna attach to it we're gonna attach to
it as inputs for different numbers which
is going to be for different step sizes
one for each curve each core will then
do the run the simulation find that the
difference at the end and return that
difference and because each course
should get a different steps initial
step size then we'll be able to compare
if we are able to find one that gives us
our desired tolerance the function that
we're gonna use is called V dot map so
from our view we use the map method and
as inputs for that map method we have
our function and the different step
sizes that we want to try the step size
it's an array of four numbers so now
these variable I think you will know
that it has to take this function take
one of these numbers and send it to a
core then take the function the second
number and send it to the core because
it's this is going to be in a
synchronous performance we manually have
to collect those responses and we're
gonna do with the get method from their
sync job object and then we find our
difference by the minimum of those four
results that we get each core returns
indifference let's try to find what's
the minimum of that one and that's the
one we check to see if it's above or
below our tolerance when we now print
the step size because we step size now
is for different numbers we're gonna
have back an array of therefore
different numbers notice how here we're
not determining exactly which of these
four numbers was the one that achieved
the desired tolerance and the reason why
I didn't do that part here is so that we
can compare the codes better like this
is closer to that all the other codes
are doing better but also notice how
when I do the parallelization then
starts adding a lot some other steps
some other additional steps that we need
and when we run that we see that we get
588 581 seconds which is roughly half of
the time that our raw code has day but
if we have four cores where we're not
getting only a fourth of the time and
part of this is that there is an
overhead for doing the parallelization
so you don't get those exact
optimizations that you will try you can
try to do then other portions like
optimizing with non PI within the while
loop that makes the call and then in
that case again you are combining some
non PI optimization with parallelism you
get again the ten seconds that you had
in the beginning because it's very hard
to combine these different things but we
can also use non PI inside the function
that is doing the calculation and these
combination I just wanted basically to
do to show you how you can within the
course in Portal library and using a PI
parallel you do the magic percentage px
and then import whichever library you
want into those course
because we are not defining which course
we want imported is gonna imported in
all of them but I'm giving you here some
sin taxes in case you wanna import it to
a specific core or when you wanna run
doesen't not just one line command but
code blocks how you have to do it so
let's go see what's the performance of
that and it's five seconds per per loop
again we are able to bring it down but
it's not so different from what we were
getting with the parallels almost one
second less than what we were getting
with a parallel alone we can also do
synchronous execution in which the only
difference is you don't have to manually
collect the results at a very big big
view level and I'm giving you the syntax
here is the same thing you had before
now it's just V dot map underline sync
but everything else is the same and you
don't need to do sync results dot get
because that's implying this synchronous
execution but the performance is again
pretty much the same so there is not
much difference between a synchronous
and synchronous within the jupiter
notebook and as long as you're not
running a lot of other processes within
within your machine and finally let's do
number with parallel processing and
let's see what we get and again the way
to do it is very easy just take the
parallel function that we were using
send it as an input to the get function
of number and run that new function that
you define with that and what you're
getting now is that the execution is 1.2
seconds still worse than what we got
initial live with number and is because
now the overhead ends up in the overhead
of sending it to do part
processes ends up being more expensive
than when you were just running your
coat by itself but that's still one
order of magnitude better than what we
started with and that's all I had to
show you guys if you ask my
recommendations is of course always
benchmark your code find where the
bottlenecks are try to optimize all that
part all the things that all those good
software practices that you guys know
about but once you have found that that
out I would recommend start with number
don't jump into parallel processing
depending on the size of your inputs you
might have to go to parallel processing
a there's a lot of different libraries
coming out for power parallel processing
in Python I haven't seen a good
comparison benchmarking all all of them
I personally find I parallel to be very
straightforward and intuitive but it
might not be and I think that is
definitely not the one with the best
performance there but as you get
comfortable with that definitely start
moving to things like multi processing
concurrent futures I am MP for PI dusk
and check those and I'll take any
questions if you have any
yes
so when G they overhead it doesn't the
overhead in sending to parallel
processing doesn't change that much but
with your with your input size so if you
have a huge input at one point even that
overhead becomes a very small part of
the whole process and it becomes worth
doing the process the parallel
processing and especially now with cloud
computing I think that's going to be
very important to keep in mind if you
have something like 72 core processors
that's definitely : that's advantage
with cloud computing that the sky's the
limit it's only limited by how much can
you pay for for those machines any other
questions
so the question is if I have any
benchmarks on other type of computations
different than just solving differential
equations right the answer is I do not
my objective will just give you some
syntax that you can use to then go and
try to apply to your specific to your
specific problem so I don't don't have
on any other thing sorry we do have time
for
oh that's that's a really good question
so on they tell me now when we start
hold on sorry yes so the question is on
the terminal when we do this where is
the IP cluster starting so you can
install it with content style you can do
it with people install IP cluster and
then what it does is just gonna start
engines for each of your course because
when we had the tutorials on Friday on
parallel processing I didn't see that
that was necessary with dusk or future
concurrence they might do it behind the
scenes with I by parallel you have to
specifically star those engines and
that's that's what it was
any other questions okay well thank you
all for coming